HOW SMART I WAS WHEN I HAD IT O
ON.
>> Tucker: THAT'S A MOTHER OF
SIX RATE THERE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
OUR FRIEND DANA PERINO WAS THE
PRESS SECRETARY  .
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
HOW WOULD YOU SUM UP THE LIFE OF
BARBARA BUSH?
>> IT WAS ONE OF GREAT
CONSEQUENCE.
SHE LIVED A LONG LIFE, SHE WAS
92 YEARS.
MOST OF IT IN PRETTY GOOD HEALTH
MOST OF IT IN PRETTY GOOD HEALT
HEALTH.
JUST LOVED BY HER FAMILY AND THE
REST OF THE WORLD, REALLY.
SHE WAS THE AMBASSADOR FROM THE
U.K. WHO WAS ON WITH MARTHA WHEN
THE NEWS BROKE THAT BARBARA BUSH
HAD PASSED.
SHE WAS BELOVED AROUND THE WORLD
AS THE BUSHES HAD MADE QUITE A
MARK ON HISTORY, BUT I THINK
THAT YOU, AS A FATHER MIGHT EVEN
RECOGNIZE THIS IN HER, BUT IF I
COULD REITERATE IT, ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT SHE AND
GEORGE H.W. BUSH DID AND RAISING
THEIR CHILDREN WAS THEY WERE
DETERMINED TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE KNEW THAT THEY WERE
LOVED UNCONDITIONALLY.
GEORGE W. BUSH IS PRESIDENT, I'M
SORRY, AFTER HE LEFT THE
PRESIDENCY, HE REALLY TOOK A LOT
OF TIME TO EXPLAIN HOW IMPORTANT
THAT WAS TO HIS FUTURE BECAUSE
YOU KNEW YOU COULD TAKE RISKS.
YOU CAN FOLLOW YOUR PATH BECAUSE
IF IT DIDN'T WORK OUT, YOUR
FAMILY WAS GOING TO BE THERE.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS INTERESTING
PARENTING LESSON FOR ME TO
UNDERSTAND.
I THINK THAT HER INFLUENCE WAS
WHAT DROVE ALL OF THAT TO THEM.
>> Tucker: ONE OF HER SONS
TOLD ME IT WAS A PIVOTAL
EXPERIENCE OF HER LIFE.
WITH LOSING HER DAUGHTER ROBIN
TO LEUKEMIA, IT'S THE ONE THING
THAT MADE HER CRY, BUT OTHER
THAN THAT, SHE HAD THIS
REMARKABLE SELF-CONTROL.
WILL HE EVER HAVE ANOTHER FIRST
LADY LIKE THAT?
I'M SERIOUS.
IT WAS A SPECIFIC KIND OF
AMERICAN-STYLE AND NOW IT'S DONE
AMERICAN-STYLE AND NOW IT'S DON
DONE.
SPEAK OUT AGAIN, HUMILITY AND A
SENSE OF HUMOR.
I REMEMBER WHEN I SPOKE ON
BEHALF OF PRESIDENT BUSH, COME
OUT WHEN I THOUGHT SHE MIGHT BE
WATCHING, I WOULD SWALLOW MY
WORDS.
IF IT WASN'T HER NOT BEING PROUD
OF US.
IT WAS REALLY SPECIAL TO KNOW
HER.
SHE AND I BONDED OVER THE FACT
THAT SHE KNEW I WAS GOING TO BE
LOYAL TO HER SON AND THE PRESS
SECRETARY AND SHE WAS ALSO A LOT
OF FUN.
I REMEMBER ONE TIME MY HUSBAND
AND I GOT TO MEET THEM AND WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THANK YOU NOTES,
ALSO AN OLD-FASHIONED THING, BUT
A TRADITION THAT I THOUGHT
SHOULD CONTINUE.
PETER CAME BACK AND WHAT I THINK
YOU KNOW.
I WAS TRAVELING AND GOT BACK AND
DIDN'T HAVE THE ADDRESS, SO IT
FINALLY GOT THERE, BUT IT WAS
ABOUT TWO AND A HALF WEEKS AFTER
OUR FIRST MEETING.
WE SAW HER NOT LONG AFTER THAT
AND THE FIRST THING SHE SAID TO
PETER WAS "THAT WAS THE LONGEST
TIME I'VE EVER HAD TO WAIT FOR
THANK YOU NOTE."
SHE SAID IT WITH A TWINKLE IN
HER EYE, BUT IT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS YOU DID NOT WANT TO
DISAPPOINT BARBARA BUSH.
>> Tucker: I HAD THAT
EXPERIENCE.
I WAS IN A PUBLIC PLACE WITH HER
ONCE IN A GYM AND I RAN INTO MY
OWN WIFE AND KISSED HER A LITTLE
BIT TOO ENTHUSIASTICALLY AND
BARBARA BUSH GIVE ME A LOOK LIKE
NONE OF THAT IN PUBLIC.
WHICH I APPRECIATED.